- I have to ask you about this photo.
So here, I'm gonna put it up for you.
This is awesome.
So, here's the thing I
love about this picture.
My kids and actually,
they gravitate towards
Ursula, not Little Mermaid.
They gravitate towards
Gaston not the Beast.
I don't know what's wrong with them.
But does yours gravitate
towards "The Grinch"
instead of Santa?
- He just loves kind of the
creepy, like aspect of things.
So he would like "Nightmare
Before Christmas"
which is, you know, a Christmas movie
- Yeah.
- But he likes like the creepyness of it.
I mean, he loves Santa.
He has the sweetest heart.
He, I don't know he is my child.
I like scary movies and
the creepy stuff too.
I swear I have not imposed
any of my stuff onto him.
And this is just what
he likes going for us.
So he loves "The Grinch"
- It's so funny, 'cause I'm opposite.
Like I don't like anything
scary and my kids love it.
Like I'm the one sitting
on the couch going,
"Why can't we just like, watch
like something really happy?"
Like why does everything
have to scare me here?
Speaking of children though, Isaiah.
So you sing a duet with him on the record.
And I saw in the special as well
there's video footage of him as well.
So was he excited to hear
himself on the record?
- He was, I had no idea
what was gonna happen.
He's never been in that
kind of situation before.
I don't think he's even been
like in the studio with me ever before.
He probably, I don't know
if he knows what I do at all
but I just thought I could hear his voice
on it in my head when I was
singing it in the studio.
And I just thought I'd ask him
and see if he might want to.
And he did such a great job
and listening back, like
I feel like he's just so proud of himself.
And he went to school and he's like,
"Hey, my songs out, wanna hear my songs."
And they were like listening
to it in his class.
- I think it's adorable.
And it's cool.
I think that when we're singers
that our kids take some kind
of interest in what we
do, that's kind of cool.
Cause we work a lot.